driving through a building looks awesome
in reality though tankers hate going
through buildings in one word it's
basements greetings all i'm nicholas
moore i commissioned as an armored
officer on m1 tanks and nm3 bradleys
these days i work as a civilian
historian for the publisher of world of
tanks today we're going to be looking at
tank battle scenes in movies and
television and judging how real they are
this is absolutely correct there's gun
crews on each side of the sponson the
tank is based off of a mark viii
international which was a very late
world war one tank built by both the uk
and us
and at the time british tanks the heavy
tanks had what were called sponson guns
the turret that wasn't on the mark
eights
shouting instructions to each other
wouldn't happen it's too loud inside a
world war one tank the entire middle of
that tank was taken up by the engine it
was massive noise what he's doing there
he's using hand signals that's the only
way to communicate inside a world war
one tank
[Music]
firing a gun with anything in the barrel
is bad you run the risk of exactly what
happened here it's called petaling
when the gun barrel just
pedals out like a flower and your gun is
done oftentimes you'll see a tank will
have a rubber
muzzle cap on the end purely to stop any
dirt at all from getting into it and
it's designed that you can actually
shoot through the muzzle cap
to my knowledge on tank fighting has
never been trained in any army
personally i'd just stuck my head at the
top used a pistol but again not very
dramatic and it will kind of suck for
indy i would have to give the scene
maybe a three on feasibility grounds
a tiger has appeared on the scene tiger
had a mythical status in world war ii it
had a reputation because it was very
very hard to kill
and because it had a heck of a gun the
8.8 centimeter was lethal to basically
everything the problem was that it looks
very much like a panzer iv which is a
lot more common in actuality historians
have found very few times on the western
front that american soldiers ever
actually met a tiger but for the
purposes of drama a tiger is fine
this was
pretty realistic drivers are absolutely
blind inside their tanks and they're
utterly reliant on instructions from the
commander so that's how you get up close
to a tank low below the line of vision
below the the level of depression that
the guns can aim at you
we're going for the wheels because the
tiger was a breakthrough tank it was
heavily armored everywhere and if you're
infantry and you don't have high
velocity cannons your best bet is to
disable the tank and get what's called a
mobility kill to immobilize the tank
your two choices are going to be either
the engine compartment
or the running gear and the only thing
that these sticky bombs are going to
have any particular effect on will be
the running gear so the sticky bomb it
was in the manual but it is also almost
a weapon of desperation the military is
supposed to give you tools for the job
like world war ii area you're talking
about the bazooka now the problem is
that you only have so many rounds of
bazook ammunition and a bazooka is only
so effective against something as
heavily armored as a tiger so you're in
desperation mode to start with
so now we see one of the problems with
the tank going on its own a tank
shouldn't go on its own for several
reasons but when you have infantry and
infestation we might like to say as
tankers crawling on your tank there's a
process is called scratching your
friends back what you do is you get on
the radio you call your buddy with a
machine gun and he will machine gun your
tank of course the bullets aren't going
to affect your tank you're in a tank but
it will very much clean off or de-louse
the infantry that are crawling on your
tank
[Applause]
and that's your example of de-lousing so
the 20 millimeter anti-aircraft gun like
any anti-aircraft going with a high rate
of fire you aim that thing horizontally
and you will do a number on infantry if
there's any big myth about tanks it's
probably that they are these
invulnerable fortresses in reality
they're not invulnerable at all and
they're absolutely reliant on the other
parts of the combined arms team you have
the desperation of lightly armed
infantry you have this back scratching
you have the immobilization of a very
dangerous tank i mean this is easily on
the ninth scale
[Applause]
and that is absolutely accurate the vast
majority of tanks that were destroyed
had no idea that the enemy was there and
again this is why you always have to
work in conjunction with infantry
because they have more eyes than you do
they have better vision than you do but
more often than not the first indication
that somebody is there is when you get
shot at and knocking off either the
first or the last tank in an ambush in a
row like that is classic
with regard to the tcs in this case
keeping their heads out
there are two schools of thought but
certainly in the time period of world
war ii all the way through the cold war
even myself it would be in a head out
positions the western school of thought
is you keep your head out
because what you don't see will kill you
the other school of thought such as used
by the soviet army in the cold war was
that you wanted to operate head down so
you closed the hatch no artillery could
affect you no snipers could affect you
and the problem of course is the reverse
you aren't able to see whatever is about
to kill you
so there is a balance to be struck
all right all thanks move forward
has decided for some reason that he is
going to charge the enemy tank
i'm not sure i would have done quite the
same thing because that simplifies the
problem for the enemy and just given
three targets in the line if you can uh
have what's called a base of fire and
then a maneuver element
then the enemy tank has a choice you can
engage the guy that's uh just sitting
there pumping accurate shots at you or
the german tank can engage the flanking
element who are coming around the side
and the 76 millimeter gun on two of
these tanks actually would destroy a
tiger
okay so being obscured the german tank
has decided to advance out of the smoke
as opposed to just sit there and wait
for whatever the enemy were going to do
the germans were very very big on
individual initiative the concept is
called australia's tactic
these days as we use the development of
it called mission command
but the bottom line is you don't wait
for orders you take the initiative you
make a decision on the spot
and that is exactly what the german has
done here
the reticle is accurate for a world war
ii american tank and shai in this case
is using the coaxial telescope so you're
going to see graduations on the reticle
each graduation is for a type of round
at a certain range so if your target is
let's say 800 yards
you will elevate the gun so that the 800
yard graduation is on the target so the
single biggest cause of missing in world
war ii was range estimation error if you
get the range wrong it doesn't matter if
your aim is
correct you will go over or short which
is why we now have modern fire control
systems to do all that mathematics for
you
if you're in this sort of a knife fight
which i wouldn't recommend getting into
in the first round set the engine alight
but that doesn't necessarily say that
the tank crew and the turret can't still
get a shot off you say you shoot at a
tank until it burns or changes shape
so keep shooting until you know that the
threat has gone this scene is an easy
knight what fury lacks in perhaps some
of the technical accuracy it more than
makes up for an understanding the
experience of being a tank crewman
tanks don't go from not to 60 just like
that they're not sports cars but they
look a lot faster than they're actually
going by comparison the m1 will do zero
to 20 miles an hour in somewhere over
seven seconds so
to be launched like that you're relying
a lot on the momentum of the truck
itself but hey it's a 60-something ton
tank it has a lot of momentum
this is obviously a derivative of some
sort of futuristic tank in reality it's
a 1960s chieftain that they've dressed
up but one of the problems you see with
this tank is you have the big glass
windows for the driver in reality you
don't want to have big glass windows on
a tank because it's a week's point
uh guys we got to come up with another
plan
[Music]
they got a tank if the opposition comes
up with a tank and you don't have
anything that's an anti-tank weapon yes
you are in a serious problem all you can
do is try to be faster than it evade it
move to where it can't see you if it can
see you it can probably shoot you
the tank is not going to slow down
because of the massive recoil of the gun
modern tanks have what's called
stabilization and what it's designed to
do is to keep the gun on target and so
with this in mind tanks are now very
capable of firing on the move my initial
thought is to give it something like a
three because yes tanks are scary tanks
will run over anything that they come
across
but the
general concept of this high speed chase
is just not there
all right so that's pierce sticking his
head out a little bit too much if you're
trying to drive a tank remember you do
have pedals for usually the brake or the
accelerator and you've got to be able to
be low enough to reach them so a tank
driver seat has two positions up or down
so head out when you're not in combat
when nobody's shooting at you uh you can
see a lot better because when you're
driving head down with a hatch close to
a little periscope
it's very easy to miss things and you
run over people that you don't want to
run over the very very latest tanks do
have cameras
rotated around but oftentimes they don't
[Music]
tanks are actually very very easy to
drive so inherently a tank is designed
to be as simple as possible to operate
especially for a soviet tank if you can
drive a car you can basically drive a
tank
some pretty cool drifting there
if you are going to drift in a tank you
either want ice or you want a soviet
track so there are two types of track
you can get on a tank generally speaking
rubber track or all steel track
and soviet tanks tended to go with an
all steel system although the metal
grousers are great for digging into dirt
and mud and getting you some excellent
cross-country traction
on a road there's very little contact
area between the track
and the tarmac cattle so what you're
doing is you're just sliding quite
literally sliding around so that
drifting was kind of fortunate that they
had a soviet tank doing this
so a tank driving through a building
looks awesome in reality though tankers
hate going through buildings if there's
any one reason that tankers hate going
through buildings in one word it's
basements because if you think about it
your typical house structure is not
designed to hold the weight of a 40
something ton vehicle above a basement
and oftentimes there is no indication
before you drive through the building
whether or not there is a basement under
you or solid ground in this case it
would appear that
he has gotten lucky
i would probably put it down more on the
five area
the definition of what is a tank is
somewhat debated the traditional
definition
often involves around the physical
characteristics it's going to have
tracks it's going to have a gun it's
going to have a turret and it's going to
have armor
but that could also be used to describe
the self-propelled artillery piece it
can be used to describe an infantry
fighting vehicle and it cannot be used
to describe the very first tanks which
had no turret or the s-tank the swedish
tank which also had no turret so these
days you're probably better off defining
a tank by its role it's a way of getting
a gun from a to b and it's very
difficult to kill so the tumbler here at
least has armor and mobility
oh it does have a gun okay i see
absolutely no practical reason why he
needs to move to a new driver's position
in order to operate this feature of the
vehicle having the room inside this
vehicle to move from one position to an
entirely new position it's bad design
because you want to have that empty
space needs to be protected by armor
that larger amount of armor weighs more
and that gives you floatation problems
emphasizing the problem you have now on
a wheeled vehicle of this extra weight
coming down on a set of wheels wheeled
vehicles don't have the advantage of the
track to spread the weight of a 60 odd
ton tank onto a piece of dirt or mud
that it doesn't sink into it
we do have an impression perhaps is just
how light this vehicle is because he is
now driving on a roof roofs are not
usually designed to hold armored
vehicles on top of them which also means
all this vehicle will do is stop perhaps
machine gun rounds and it's not going to
stop a rocket-propelled grenade or an
anti-tank round as for the vehicle
itself i don't think that there is any
actual equivalent
in military service around the world the
closest might be for something like a
reconnaissance vehicle so there's a
vehicle called the fennec and that is in
appearance very similar sort of an
angled 4x4
and it's designed to be fairly fast
fairly low profile to sneak around the
battlefield and do reconnaissance for
what it is i'll give it a 7.
the tanks that they're using are also
very good vis mods a visual modification
what we have here is an earlier version
of today's american tank the m1 abrams
and it's basically the version that i
was on when i was in iraq for a moment i
was in disbelief that they had used
actual m1s because the m1 has a jet
engine it has an extremely distinctive
sound
and in this movie you hear the engine
starting and the sound designers put in
the turbine engine
and that was enough pause that you
realize
are they abrams so what they've done is
they've taken british centurions they've
made it into an m1
real tanks don't drive that close you're
going to have one or 200 yards in
between tanks because if you're that
close you make yourself a perfect target
for artillery or aircraft or anything
else with a blast radius
why why give the enemy an easy shot the
idea of this battle happening at night
is absolutely in line with american
doctrine of the time set in the 1991
gulf war commonly known as desert storm
the u.s in particular owned the night
with modern night vision gear it cannot
be understated the advantage that these
pieces of equipment would give over
their enemies who could not see or fight
at night the most famous of the 91
battles like this was called 73 easting
a swarm of tanks coming at you firing on
the move at night you can't see them all
you know is that there's explosions and
your own tanks are blowing up and it was
absolute textbook shock attack and it
has become one of the most famous
battles in u.s armor branch history ever
since
so what he's holding there is i believe
it's a pbs7 it's an earlier version of
an image intensifier that we use even
today on these earlier m1 tanks the
commander's handheld vision is not as
good as the thermal imager
all right baby hold on they got no range
the commander is dropped down he's now
looking through what's called the
gunners primary site extension
and this allows him to see exactly what
the gunner is looking at calm down calm
down son find me another target
[Music]
so the coordination in here is perfectly
reasonable the crew of the m1 is the
driver loader gunner and commander the
commander
confirms the target he gives the fire
command the loader loads around arms the
gun
yells up he keeps back out of the way
because he doesn't want to get hit by
that 120 as it comes back to him
it's absolutely reasonable
uh that there would have been personnel
outside of the hatches shooting machine
guns if they had to get that close now
ordinarily you wouldn't want to get that
close you'd actually stop and you will
let the infantry that you're supposed to
be operating with the last hundred yards
while the tanks provide the overwatching
support
i heard you what
oh my god
so he has just fired and engaged a
friendly tank it's called in army speak
a blue on blue now friendly fire has
been a problem since day one of ranged
combat the problem that you had with the
m1 especially with the early thermal
imagers was that it was much much better
at spotting targets than it was at
identifying them and at a long range or
if surrounded by fire such as it is here
you didn't always know for sure what it
was that you were engaging and the other
problem is the friendly fire has become
a lot more of a thing
because recent combat has been so
lopsided
that if the enemy kills one of your guys
you know it they will have to live with
the effects of they have just killed
their friends which is exactly the
premise of the movie here so i'd have to
give him a nine overall the tank battle
scene and courage on the fire are
excellent
let's go all right
every tanker i know wants to be oddball
secretly and i'm guilty of that too
[Music]
we tried hooking up a loudspeaker to our
tank wants to play music it didn't work
out unfortunately
okay so oddball has fired a paint round
such things do not exist but oddball is
oddball what he has done though given
the situation that kelly and oddball
were in that's pretty much how i'd do it
if you're going to shoot at the tiger
the rear is the place you're going to do
it
if i was the german tanker i probably
would not have gone down this road in
the first place tanks rule in open area
like deserts in urban areas and in dense
forest
infantry rule
and this is part of the reason why since
you can't see the corners like you can
in a car you are reliant on somebody on
the outside telling you which way to go
forwards backwards left or right this is
the sort of situation where you need
infantry subject to minor details like a
tank which fires paint rounds has a
large loudspeaker on the side to play
morale boosting music that's actually a
pretty good scene so i'd give that maybe
an eight another mandatory movie for
tankers my favorite tank movie well
you know very very difficult because
it's a three-way fight two of them we've
seen here fury and kelly's heroes the
third one that i call out is the beast
which is from the 1980s it's about a
soviet tank crew lost in afghanistan
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
why not click on the video above